hello and welcome to another a pack
developer office hours we have a room
full of people for once today the
multiple people connecting so let's do
it around and introduce ourselves yeah
hi everyone I'm Billy hi I'm Scott from
Tokyo hi I'm under the listing from
Heidelberg I rice Lee visiting from
metroburg we said visiting because we're
actually out of the office style usual
officers today hi I'm anchor and from
the Sydney office I'm Tom Lee are
visiting from hong kong all right well
let's get started with the questions we
have six this week and we'll start off
with the urine yeah so let me not the
first question yeah it says it's why I'm
drew Kenney and the question is i read
with c2dm that if the app is open i
should update the UI rather than force
to notification to the status bar is
there an easy way my broadcast receiver
to know if the app is open so that I can
file update my intent and not sure
notification yes this can be done using
the activity manager so you get a handle
in the activity manager and you get the
list of running processes and you can
check whether your process is in the or
which processes in foreground has a
program priority and then will tell you
whether your application your activity
of your UI is on in that case you can
love the infancy of you i right fastest
to actually for the next question yeah
thnkx enabled the next question is from
Bobby term fats question is on content
providers is it possible to build a file
content provider to access and ftp
server okay so content providers are
basically a mechanism for multiple apps
on the same device to share data and
theoretically the answer is yes you can
use a content provider to in interfaces
to build a wrapper on top of accessing
ftp so
on the grout now the concept of
accessing ftp a using FTP protocol is
very different from the way the content
provider interfaces are filled so you'll
have to think and design in a way where
the sequel kind of interfaces like
insert query delete and update are
translated to relevant queries or
commands in the 50 protocol and it will
be interesting if limitation to look at
but yeah the answer is yes you can do it
but you have to think about how you
translate sequel life and I'm to active
easy for the corner you can be
interesting to see how what use case I
was going to say the same thing I'd be
really interesting to hear what what's
one really wants to do this know why
they want to create this case that by an
episode yeah don't drop us a comment in
the and the thread yes Obama drama let
us know you're building it sounds really
interesting yeah ok so what the next
question oh ok oh yes so the next
question is um I have a list of shaked
robots that I am adding to a view and
after each addition I am calling
invalidate on the view I thought that
invited with the force ecology on their
own but it doesn't we undergo give me a
fresh canvas at each other oh ok the
Christian here is that I think it is
important to understand that there's no
guarantee that ah yes there is no
guarantee on when we are calling on the
road from the platform and so the you
can invalidate the view anytime but
there is no guarantee as to when I'm
under a way to help them and still are
you can expect that on the record will
happen every time before actual visual
happens but the if you have to do
anything on the road but
you cannot read I really did I on land
or don't already have and so the another
question where we under give me a fresh
canvas at each 10 that's true yeah so
the kind of object itself may be
recycled yeah but the canvas itself will
be blank every two androids called right
and another thing I'd like to mention
instead make sure you are on you I said
when they buy you are invalidating the
view otherwise you will yeah the context
valued sorry this is from NIMH Bolton in
Ho Chi Minh City Vietnam the context
value is intended for the activity in
the face but a lot of tiny operations
like needed like internet connection
checking or getting app folder or device
dimensions so what's the best way to
handle this within threats so you're
absolutely right that an activity can be
used as a context but you can't
guarantee that that activity is always
going to be around for the entire
duration of your your apps lifecycle
especially if you have multiple
activities so what you should be doing
in this situation is for context you
should actually be getting the
application context and not passing
around the activity as your context so
it's a simple call to get application
context on the activity itself or you
know it's available on a number of
classes and from there you can pass that
around and use it how you wish so then
option you can look at this maybe you if
you really want to pass it and there's
no other option you can pass a week
reference of the activity context so
even if activity is killed so your dick
reference will be there is no memory
leak right right and your preference
would be garbage collected on one
pattern i've seen is by using the
application context the application
context
self as you can extend the application
class which android app application in
your code and that's basically my
limitation of your application and you
can put a matter then get context as a
static so you can always say application
don't get context which will give you
your application context so that's
that's another way of obtaining the
application context anywhere even if
your activity context it is okay so um i
would take a little questions so the
next question is also coming from
Templeton so I have a process that I
want to be running continuously in the
background of my application it has to
stay sleeping until there's some data in
the database how to make it wake up when
data is inserted in the pb async tops
all threat which is best so for this all
other questions you what you can do is
you can you can further running
continues in your background piece you
can actually use the service arm and to
listening to database changes are in the
sequel I'd database there is actually
built in functionality so you can
register an observer content web server
to to listen to changes in the database
so basically in our insert update or
delete you just need to call the method
Oh device change and whatever observers
you register to to the database will are
invoked sort of methods when when they
just got changes cool so the last
question yep so last question is coming
from man portugal from a username that
looks like it's ready but Elsa at
Bordeaux Saurez dub PT and the question
is is it possible to set up manually IP
mask gateway and dns server in a Wi-Fi
connection programmatically and android
ICS if yes how unfortunate the answer is
no there is no programmatic way to do it
so it's a short answer it can't be done
today
cool thanks to that building Tony do
want to just check whether there's any
questions on the live thread on google+
I'm just well Tony's doing that I guess
one exciting thing today that we posted
the schedule for Google i/o so make sure
you go to the google i/o site and check
out what sessions there are there are a
number of android sessions and some of
us will be presenting at birth and
there's code labs and lots of cool
things so certainly go check those out
it's going to be out an exciting time
and looking forward to all of you being
at i/o are much watching the sessions
but should be using I online yeah
absolutely everything will be screams
fun years yes as you know that's a very
good point so if if you want one of the
fortunate few to get tickets you will
have an opportunity to distill tune in
to all our sessions are we looking at
Tony well well it's very quiet today
then all right well in that case I guess
we will will sign off don't look like
anyone else afternoon the corporation so
thank you very much for your time and
we'll be back again next week so see you
then okay